we are approaching the end of day eight
students are still working today the
first day that they're off on their own
I didn't record a confessional last
night so I sort of forgot to but
yesterday was the last official day of
lecture it was on post-production that's
been a challenge to balance context and
sort of a more bigger picture digital
literacy understanding the medium type
things with just the practical things
that they need to know to be their
project and given a small amount of time
there's always been a compromise of
something yesterday was great I think
when I heard Josh read his script he's
one of my favorite moments in class
first of all his idea had come such a
long way and his delivery was very good
too and he said that he would he had
washed Andrea the day before and tried
to pick up pick up tips from her I'm
happy with this community of students
that have come together for this class
and I think in part a lot of that has
happened because it's small enough
seeing them hair off to work on their
projects they have really helped each
other a lot and certain personalities
have come through that we're super quiet
Jamie and I were very deliberate with
how we group people up for their final
projects then hard to balance the
practical skills with context I sent out
this midpoint survey to the students
yesterday and someone had said it was
really really packed the first week in
all of a sudden the pressure has been
released in I could find a better way to
spread out all that stuff I think it'd
be more ideal oh the other thing is how
thinking about how this is this could be
a scalable experience I can't imagine
this class going over ten people and I
think the thing that's been most
valuable is
I might have mentioned this before but
can easily teach best practices you can
easily talk about techniques you can
even show the examples you can go from
concept to example or people can
acknowledge that and people can critique
other people's work but then
transferring it to the final layer of
being self-aware enough itself
reflective enough to you your work with
that same could fly and in some sense
like being able to cultivate taste of
whom people is is really hard I don't
know if I'm really doing it and Who am I
to say that I have the best taste
anything a lot of times questions are
posed opening with is it okay is it okay
if I do this is it okay if i change this
is it okay if i go to this location I
know that what they're trying to ask is
you recommend this but it's just
striking the way that's so ubiquitously
posed I don't want the mentality to be
that I'm sort of end-all be-all any more
than anything I want the self-awareness
though if someone made a terrible video
but they could say I think this is bad
and I think maybe this is why I think
that that's ultimately where we need to
be more self awareness in science
communication